first aid kit check game console with
blu-ray player check complete printout
of TV tropes org
check sorry I can't rat now I'm too busy
prepping for the end of civilization as
we know it the signs are everywhere just
look at the egregious errors in basic
logic that are allowed to exist in
today's TV pop culture the best example
of this today is NBC's revolution the
supposedly realistic look at how the
world would change if inert air
populated nanomachines rendered every
electrical appliance inoperable the show
would have us believe that humanity
would turn into some sort of weird Amish
cowboys who force where the riding of
bicycles while they fight pitched
battles over horses and wagons with the
few remaining bullets if the showrunners
had spent a little less time dreaming up
urban ruins and a little more time
reading any work of steampunk they
realized that the actual result of these
nanomachines would be to unleash
Industrial Revolution 2 point 0 within a
few years Connecticut Yankee types and
Maker Faire stalwarts would be cranking
out steam powered jet skis and
self-aware difference engines and
apparently a lot of brass monocles I
don't know why there's always have those
anyway Syfy's defiance presents us with
the same sort of inexplicably old-school
dystonia in this future apocalypse
scenario a massive influx of aliens and
interspecies war and extensive
environmental changes on earth result in
a sons of anarchy in the Old West kind
of milieu I don't get it there's funky
alien technology all around but the
characters dress like they just got back
from an inauguration party for
rutherford b hayes did a network exec
get a great deal on the old sets and
props from dr. Quinn Medicine Woman
gratulations revolution in defiance your
doomsday scenarios managed to be less
plausible than the one in that
apocalyptic Seth Rogen movie no not this
is the end I'm talking about Green
Hornet
and what a disaster that was and don't
get me started on the logical flaws in
zombie movies what do you think Walking
Dead gets wrong about societal collapse
leave a comment or better yet a video
reply I'll give a special prize for the
best one